lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
algo fuera de lo común he intentado este
problema antes de empezar a grabar el
vídeo y de varias formas lo he intentado
y siempre obtuve una respuesta distintas
una respuesta distinta a las que están
aquí así que suponiendo que los que
hicieron el examen lo hicieron bien y es
que este examen es muy serio y es para
para ingresar a muchas universidades de
prestigio en india así que vamos a
suponer que no cometieron errores y me
gustaría que alguno de ustedes que está
viendo este vídeo me dijera dónde estoy
cometiendo un error y el problema dice
así dice sean pq números reales tales
que p no es cero p elevado al cubo es
distinto de q y p elevado al cubo es
distinto de menos q ahora si alfa y beta
son números complejos distintos de cero
que cumplen que su suma es decir alfa +
beta es menos p y alfa al cubo
más beta al cubo es decir la suma de sus
cubos es q entonces una ecuación
cuadrática que tienen como raíces
alva / beta
beta / alfa es y nos dan estas cuatro
opciones entonces yo no he podido
encontrar la respuesta correcta entonces
vamos a tratar de hacerlo en el vídeo y
ustedes me dirán dónde estoy cometiendo
el error muy bien entonces vamos a ver
esto si yo quiero un polinomio o una una
ecuación cuadrática y si escuadra tica
es decir es un polinomio de grado 2 y
debe tener como raíces a estos dos
entonces podemos ir explorando qué pasa
con x - alfa / beta verdad por x menos
beta / alfa este es una ecuación
cuadráticas y luego lo igualamos a 0
verdad y además estos dos son nuestras
raíces así que ahora vamos a ir
desarrollando tenemos x cuadrada
si x por x luego x por menos beta / al
resto es menos beta / alfa x luego -
alfa / beta x - alfa / beta x y luego -
alfa entre beta por - beta / alfa y
realmente los signos se cancelan se
hacen más y alfa / alfa si cancela beta
entre beta se cancela y nos queda 1
igual a 0 muy bien entonces lo que
podemos hacer ahorita es multiplicar de
ambos lados por alfa beta es decir
multiplicamos este lado por alfa beta y
también multiplicamos del lado derecho
ahora del lado derecho realmente pues
multiplicar 0 por lo que ustedes quieran
sigue siendo 0 verdad entonces esto será
igual a 0 y el detalle es que al
multiplicar por alfa beta de este lado
que es lo que nos queda si distribuimos
nos queda alfa beta por equis cuadrada
muy bien y luego alfa beta por menos
beta entre alfa las alfa se cancelan y
me queda beta cuadrada y con el signo
menos
- ve está cuadrada por equis y ahora
alfa beta por menos alfa / beta las
betas se cancelan y me quedan menos alfa
por alfa que es alfa cuadrada x muy bien
y luego alfa beta por 1 pues simplemente
es alfa beta y déjenme déjenme poner
para acomodar esto donde debería ir muy
bien entonces aquí me falta escribir más
alfa beta y esto debe ser 0 muy bien
entonces si nos damos cuenta aquí ya
está todo en términos de alfa si de
betas pero en realidad nuestras opciones
que nos dan aquí sólo están en términos
de pq entonces este problema lo tenemos
lo tenemos que convertir a en términos
de pq nada más voy a simplificar un poco
esto porque puedo agrupar esto tengo
alfa beta x cuadrada esto lo dejamos
igual y luego voy a restar
alfa cuadrada + beta cuadrada que
multiplica x y aquí estamos agrupando
este término y este otro verdad factor
izamos un menos factor izamos la equis y
luego nos queda alfa cuadrada más beta
cuadrada y ahora sumó alfa beta igual a
cero entonces esta expresión de aquí
insisto ya está en términos de alfa y
beta ahora hay que tratar de
convertirlos a pq para ver cuál de estas
opciones es la que nos da entonces qué
es lo que podemos usar podemos usar que
alfa + beta es menos p entonces fíjense
si tengo menos p igual a alfa más beta
esto esto es esta hipótesis verdad nos
dicen que alfa + beta es menos p
entonces queremos llegar digamos como
alfa el cubo más beta al cubo vamos a
ver si podemos lograrlo entonces qué
pasa si elevamos al cuadrado de ambos
lados y nos quedan menos p
al cuadrado y esto simplemente es p
cuadrada verdad
- p por menos p - por menos es más
p por p esp cuadrado entonces ahí
quedamos y luego elevamos alfa más beta
al cuadrado eso es alfa cuadrada más 2
alfa beta más beta cuadrada verdad es
simplemente la fórmula de un binomio al
cuadrado y ahora porque estoy elevando a
las potencias pues justamente quiero
encontrar alfa al cubo y bet al cubo
suma 2 entonces quizás sí elevó yo p al
cubo puede encontrarlo vamos a ver si
tenemos
vamos a ver si tenemos menos pe al cubo
esto simplemente será menos p al cubo
verdad porque menos 1 al cubo es menos 1
x menos 1 x menos uno que es menos 1 y
luego el cubo este al cubo y ya y ahora
pues no sé podríamos hacerlo de
distintas formas por ejemplo podríamos
multiplicar esto por alfa + beta o
simplemente elevar alfa más beta al cubo
y eso resolverlo con el triángulo de
pascal vamos a hacerlo de esa forma se
acaban del triángulo de pascal es 1
pongo 1 y 1 1 2 y 1 y aquí voy en el
piso 2 y aquí vamos al piso 3 13 31
entonces estos son los coeficientes de
cuando elevamos un binomio al cubo
verdad si si tienes dudas de cómo
estamos utilizando el el triángulo de
pascal te recomiendo que vayas a los
vídeos de sobre todo el teorema del
binomio muy bien entonces este menos p
al cubo va a ser alfa + beta
y esto es alfa al cubo aquí va el uno
más tres que es el siguiente coeficiente
alfa cuadrada beta más tres alfa beta
cuadrada más beta al cubo entonces lo
único que puse fueron los coeficientes
de este nivel del triángulo de pascal y
después puse potencias de alfa y beta
las potencias de alfa van disminuyendo
hasta desaparecer y las de beta van
aumentando muy bien entonces lo que
podemos notar aquí es que tengo ahora si
mi alfa al cubo y me beta al cubo muy
bien entonces esto lo puedo poner como
menos p al cubo es menos b al cubo y
sabemos que alfa al cubo mas veta al
cubo por hipótesis es q entonces aquí
podemos poner déjenme ponerlo así alfa
al cubo más venta al cubo primero y
luego terminamos sumando el resto
3 alfa cuadrada beta más 3 alfa beta
cuadrada y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
ir simplificando fíjense muy bien
tenemos ya esto y entonces me queda
menos p al cubo ya empezamos de aquí
debe ser igual a alfa al cubo más beta
al cubo pero alfa el cubo más beta al
cubo es q verdad entonces aquí tengo
aquí tengo aquí y luego factor hizo de
esto verde que me queda por factorizar
tres veces alfa beta tengo tres veces
alfa beta que multiplica a alfa más beta
verdad simplemente fue factor izando 3
alfa beta pero alfa + beta alfa + beta
es menos p es menos p y eso está aquí
verdad entonces vamos a reescribir lo
esto simplemente es menos p
nos pega el cubo igual a q mas 3 alfa
beta por menos p muy bien y entonces
nosotros podemos despejar alfa beta y
que nos sirve mucho justamente porque
aquí tenemos alfa civetas de hecho alfa
beta verdad entonces vamos a tratar de
despejarlo
por ejemplo pasamos restando q y nos
queda menos para el cubo menos q igual a
igual a menos 3 alfa beta por p verdad
simplemente pasando el signo menos hasta
acá y ahora dividimos todo entre menos 3
p dividimos todo entre menos 3 p y nos
queda menos p al cubo menos q sobre
menos 3 p esto es igual a alfa beta muy
bien y este menos lo que puede hacer es
simplemente tengo aquí menos esto entre
menos esto pues los menos se cancelan y
simplemente escribir p al cubo
sobre 3 p esto es igual a alfa por beta
muy bien y esto esta expresión nos cae
muy bien y justamente por lo siguiente
notemos notemos que hay quien sería alfa
cuadrada más b está cuadrada aquí aquí
tenemos un alfa cuadrada más b está
cuadrada tenemos que determinar quién es
eso verdad pero también tenemos aquí
esta parte este alfa
si no tenemos aquí alfa cuadrada más b
está cuadrada es p cuadrada muy bien
entonces y además tenemos aquí dos alfa
beta y ya sabemos quién es alfa beta
entonces podemos calcularlo muy bien
alfa cuadrada más b está cuadrada verdad
si lo tomamos de esta ecuación es p
cuadrada
menos dos alfa beta y eso sale de aquí
arriba muy bien pero alfa beta ya
sabemos quién es entonces esto será de
cuadrada menos dos veces alfa beta que
es p outs dije p
al cubo más q sobre 3 p muy bien
entonces tenemos esto y vamos a sacar un
común divisor entonces si dividimos
bueno si queremos expresar p cuadrada
con denominador 3 p esto será 3 p al
cubo entre 3 p verdad los 13 cancelan y
p al cubo entre p esp cuadrada menos 2 p
al cubo déjenme ponerlo así incluso
- 2 p al cubo vamos a distribuir lo
menos 2 q entre 3 p y si nosotros
sumamos esto que nos queda tenemos 3 p
al cubo menos 2 p al cubo así que me
queda sólo 1 solo me queda 1 verdad
entonces esto será igual a p al cubo
menos 2 q entre 3 p porque tenemos el
mismo el mismo denominador entonces ya
podemos ir
simplificando todo esto de la siguiente
forma porque fíjense tengo alfa beta
entonces este alfa beta este alfa beta
lo puedo sustituir por esta expresión de
aquí entonces tengo p al cubo más q
entre 3 p que multiplica nuestra x
cuadrada menos menos esta expresión de
aquí entonces de hecho esta expresión de
aquí es justamente esta de aquí muy bien
tenemos esta de aquí entonces menos
p al cubo menos 2 q entre 3 p que
multiplica a x muy bien más alfa beta
nuevamente tenemos alfa beta por segunda
ocasión aquí entonces más que al cubo
más q entre 3 p y esto debe ser igual a
0 verdad entonces seguimos teniendo la
misma ecuación cuadrática pero alfa y
beta después de resolver muchas
operaciones ya lo dejamos en términos de
pib muy bien entonces en realidad si nos
fijamos en nuestras respuestas en
nuestras posibles respuestas aquí nunca
están dividiendo entre 3 p y la ventaja
que tenemos en ese sentido es que
estamos igualando a cero así que si por
ejemplo multiplicamos de ambos lados por
tres p
qué es lo que nos quedaría pues se
cancela se cancelan los 3 p que quedan
abajo en el denominador de cada término
entonces nos queda p al cubo más q que
multiplica a equis cuadrada menos
p al cubo menos 2 q que multiplica x más
p al cubo más q verdad que bueno esto lo
podemos agrupar en derecho y esto es
igual a cero entonces déjenme copiar
déjenme seleccionar esto para ver si
coincide con alguna de nuestras
respuestas
a copiarlo
y ver si coincide
y aquí lo tenemos
y estamos muy contentos porque ahora sí
no sé cómo le dice ahora que sí me salió
y de hecho la respuesta es la ve verdad
así que ahí está la respuesta esto es
esta es la respuesta correcta estoy
bastante emocionado me retracto de lo
que les había dicho al inicio realmente
creo que no necesite su ayuda al final
bueno quizás si necesita su ayuda verdad
en el proceso de enseñanza esa era la
ayuda que necesitaba pero bueno de
cualquier forma espero que este
ejercicio te haya resultado útil